[تصفيق]
من اول ما بدات دراسه عماره
طريقه رؤيتي لكل حاجه اتغيرت وكمان طريقه
تفكير اتغيرت عرفت ان مشاعرنا بتتكون من
افكارنا وافكارنا بتشكل قراراتنا
وعرفت كمان انه كل واحد لو عايز مشاعر
ايجابيه لازم يكون يختار افكار ايجابيه
لان ذراعه النهارده بنحسده بكره
[تصفيق]
عرفت كمان قوه صناعه القرار واهميتها وان
كل قرار بناخده النهارده بيسمع في
المستقبل وكمان على مدى القريب ومن هنا
قررت اني اكون على قد ما اقدر ايجابي
ومبادر
مش كل حاجه حوالينا حلوه وما نقدرش نشوف
كل حاجه حلوه لكن نقدر نشوف الحلو في كل
حاجه
[تصفيق]
كل مره كنت بدخل مبنى قديم مسجد او كنيسه
كنت منبهر بالتفاصيل اللي بتبقى موجوده في
الاسقف بتاعه المباني دي وكان دايما عندي
حلم ان انا في يوم من الايام اقدر اعمل
سقف زي ده
وفي 2018 جبت ورقه وقلم وبدات اصمم سقف
للاوضه عندي
ولما وريته لاهلي وحسيت ان هم ما عندهمش
مانع ان انا انفذه انتهزت الفرصه جبت
السلم وبدات ارسم بالقلم الرصاص واحده
واحده وبعد كده بدات الون لحد لما في
الاخر وصلت للنتيجه دي
[تصفيق]
ساعات كتير بيجي في بالي يا ترى ايه
مستقبل العماره في مصر وفي العالم كله
والمباني اللي احنا بنشوفها دي مستقبلها
هيكون ايه
في مباني كتير حوالينا بس ممكن تكون غير
قابله للاستخدام وده بسبب اهمال او بسبب
تغير نشاط في المبنى
فاصبح المبنى غير مرغوب فيه وللاسف برغم
القيمه اللي ممكن تكون وراء المباني دي
بيكون مصيرها هو الهدم
وده طبعا بياثر سلبيا جامد جدا على البيئه
بسبب انبعاثات الكربون اللي بتطلع وكمان
المواد اللي بتبقى مش عارفين نتخلص منها
ازاي طيب هو ايه الحل هل في طريقه تانيه
نقدر نتعامل بها مع المباني دي الاجابه هي
اه بدل ما نهد المباني نقدر نفكر في اعاده
احيائها ونشوف ايه الاستخدام اللي
محتاجينه فعلا ونقدر نتعامل مع المبنى ده
لتطويره ونعيد استخدامه النوع ده من
الاستخدام مع المباني اسمه
او اعاده استخدام المباني
طبعا لازم نراعي الجانب الاقتصادي علشان
نقدر نوفر ونغطي التكلفه اللي احنا
صرفناها في التطوير ده
ممكن نشوف مشروع زيلو في الدنمارك
اتحول صومعتين لتخزين الاسمنت الاربعه
وثمانين وحده سكنيه يقدر الناس يعيشوا
فيها
والفكره كانت في استغلال الفيو ففكر
المعماري ان هو يخلي الوحدات كلها بصه على
الفيو ويخلي الخدمات تكون هي اللي جوه
تخيلوا قد ايه المشروع ده اضاف قيمه
اقتصاديه
وبيئيه وكمان جماليه في المكان ده
ممكن نشوف كمان مشروع زي قنصليه اللي كان
مقر القنصليه الفرنسيه وسط البلد وبعد كده
القنصليه اتنقلت الجيزه فبدل ما المبنى
يبدا يفضل فاضي شركه الاسماعيليه طورته
وحولته
تقدر الناس تروح تشتغل فيه
النوع ده من الاستخدام يقدر ان هو يساعدنا
ان احنا نتعامل مع مشكله بتواجه العالم
وهي التغير المناخي
[تصفيق]
كل يوم النهارده بصحى افتح طيب يا جماعه
احنا النهارده بقى ايه هنلبس صيفي ولا
هنلبس شتوي الجو بصراحه ما بقاش مفهوم
وكلنا حاسين بالتغير ده كل سنه
طيب هو فين المشكله يعني او ليه العلماء
والابحاث بتقول ان التغير المناخي ده
تعتبر اهم مشكله العالم محتاج يواجهها
النهارده
ببساطه التغير المناخي معناه ان كل سنه
درجه حراره العالم بتعلى
الطبيعي ان احنا عايشين في العالم بسبب
الغلاف الجوي اللي بيقدر ان هو ياخد جزء
من اشعه الشمس علشان يخلي درجه الحراره
قابله للحياه بس بسبب نشاط الانسان
الزياده وحرقه للزيوت والوقود للاسف بتطلع
انبعاثات كربون كتيره جدا والكربون ده
مشكلته ان هو بيحبس نسبه كبيره من الاشعه
دي جوه الارض وبالتالي درجه الحراره بتعلى
وده اللي بيؤدي لكوارث كتير اللي احنا كل
شويه بنسمع عنها في اماكن كثيره في العالم
[تصفيق]
مجال المباني مسؤول لوحده عن 30 ل 40% من
اجمالي انبعاثات الكربون اللي بتطلع في
العالم كله
ومن هنا نقدر نشوف ان مستقبل العماره ان
احنا نتوجه ناحيه العماره الخضراء
والمقصود بالعماره الخضراء هي المباني
اللي بتتعمل علشان تحافظ على البيئه بان
هي توفر في ثلاث حاجات اساسيه الطاقه
والميه والخامات
وفي شهادات كتير النهارده المبنى يقدر
ياخدها لما يثبت ان هو محقق المعايير دي
مش بقول طبعا ان المستقبل هيبقى المباني
كلها وغاده الشهادات دي لكن نقدر نستخدم
المعايير دي في ان احنا نتعامل معها
ونراعيها في التصميم من البدايه خالص في
اي مبنى نقدر نعمله يكون مستدام
بمناسبه ان احنا بنتكلم على الاستدامه
فخبراءه علماء الاقتصاد بيقولوا ان
النهارده كل بلد محتاجه تبدا مشوارها في
الاكتفاء الذاتي في ثلاث حاجات اساسيه
الاكل
والصحه والطب والدواء
وكمان التعليم والتكنولوجيا كلنا متابعين
اللي بيحصل في العالم حوالينا وشوفنا قد
ايه ان ممكن مشاكل بين دول تؤثر على دول
ثانيه في منتجاتها وسلاحها الاساسيه
طيب هو ده ايه علاقته مستقبل العماره
الارقام بتقول لنا ان بعشرين خمسين
70% من سكان العالم كلهم هيبقوا عايشين في
المدن
وده يخلينا نبص للمدينه على ان هي مورد
مهم جدا لازم نتعامل معاه بشكل مستدام
[تصفيق]
في اسطح بيوت كتير حوالينا ممكن تكون
عباره عن بواقي خزين او موبيليا بقى لها
كثير منسيه تخيلوا ان المنظر ده ممكن يكون
ده
في الحقيقه كل عماره سكنيه ممكن تشترك مع
بعض وتزرع السطح بتاعها
ويقدروا ياكلوا منه خضار وفاكهه بسعر قليل
وكمان قريب من البيت وفي نفس الوقت نقدر
ان احنا نخلي السكان يعرفوا بعض اكتر
وبكده نقدر ان احنا نقرب بشكل كبير
للاكتفاء الذاتي في الطعام كمان الزراعه
مش ميزتها بس ان هي بتدي اكل لكن كمان
بتعزل الادوار الاخيره من الحراره والمطره
اللي معظم سكان الاضرار الاخير بيشتكوا
منه
[تصفيق]
ممكن كمان نبدا نزرع في كل الادوار وان
المباني تكون مصممه من الاول علشان كده
بحيث ان هي تبقى اسهل من السطح
كلنا عارفين ان الزرع بنجيب منه اكل بس هل
ممكن الزرع نطلع منه ماده نقدر نبني بها
مباني
[تصفيق]
كم واحد فينا عايش في مباني مبنيه من
الخرسانه
الحقيقه خمسين في الميه من اجمالي المباني
اللي موجوده في العالم كله مبنيه
بالخرسانه واكثر من 70% من سكان العالم
عايشين في مباني معموله من الخرسانه
وللاسف الخرسانه هي اكتر ماده ملوثه
للبيئه في مجال الانشاءات وده لان هي
جواها اسمنت والاسمنت ده علشان نعمله لازم
ندخل الحجر الجيري الفرن على درجه حراره
1500 لوقت كتير جدا وده طبعا بيطلع
انبعاثات كتيره وبالتالي بتلوش الجو
طيب النهارده ما نقدرش نقول ان في خامه
تقدر تحل محل الخرسانه بشكل متكامل لكن في
محاولات كتير على الارض
بان احنا نستخدم مواد طبيعيه علشان نعمل
منها مواد نقدر نبني بها ومنها
اللي وزنها نص وزن الخرسانه
مرات احسن من الخرسانه
[تصفيق]
على فكره
المعماري مهمته مش ان هو بس يحل مشاكل
الانسان على الارض لكن كمان في القمر في
2019 وكاله ناسا عملت مسابقه عشان تشوف
رؤيه المصممين للحياه على القمر عامله
ازاي
وفعلا في مكتب اسمه بيج وده من اكبر
المكاتب المصممه في العالم كله تعرضت مع
ناسا علشان تنفذ المشروع ده بحلول عام
2028 بتكلفه 93 بليون دولار عن طريق الثري
دي برنتنج او البناء بالروبوت
نج مش حاجه جديده
[تصفيق]
في مشاريع كثيره مبنيه
ما نقدرش نقول ان هو دلوقتي جاهز ان هو
يحل محل الخرسانه او مواد البناء عامه
اللي موجوده لكن بما اننا بنتكلم
عن التكنولوجيا دي وعيده جدا ان هي يكون
لها مستقبل كتير في الرياده في السوق قدام
شويه وده بسبب ان هي تقدر تستخدم منها
مواد محليه زي الطين وده بيفكرنا بمقوله
المعماري حسن فتحي لما قال انظر تحت قدميك
وابني وبصراحه الفلسفه دي مش مرتبطه بوقت
معين ولا بستايل معين لكن الفلسفه دي هي
فعلا منهج علشان الانسان يفكر باستدامه
ويشوف طبيعه المكان اللي هو فيه ويبني
بالخامات اللي موجوده به
وطبعا باستخدام اعلى تكنولوجيا بما اننا
بنتكلم عن التكنولوجيا
فبنهايه ثوره الثوره الصناعيه حصلت طفره
في صناعه المكنه وفي عمال كتير كان عندهم
تخوف ان المكن ده ممكن يحل محلهم او يعدهم
في البيت
كمان وقت الكالكوليتر
الناس حست ان ممكن الانسان يبطل يشغل
دماغه بس في الحقيقه اللي حصل عكس كده
النهارده احنا بنعيش طفره جديده ما تقلش
اهميتها عن صناعه المكن
انت ممكن تكونوا خمنتوها
[تصفيق]
او الذكاء الصناعي النهارده في مجال
التصميم ومجال العماره نقدر ان احنا ندخل
معايير معينه للمباني
ونقول مثلا مساحه الارض والادوار اللي
احنا عايزينها ونسيب الذكاء الصناعي يدينا
مقترحات كتيره جدا في وقت قليل
وطبعا نقدر ان احنا نختار التصميم اللي
ممكن يكون مناسب للمكان ده طبعا مع اضافه
العنصر البشري فيه
[تصفيق]
النهارده العالم بيقرب جدا من بعض كلنا
شفنا وقت الكوفيد
انه الانسان عرف يتاقلم ويعيش حياته عادي
خالص ويكمل شغله ويكمل دراسه
عن طريق التكنولوجيا وده اللي فتح باب
العالم جديد وهو العالم الافتراضي او
الميتافيرس
بالفعل في شركات كتيره جدا عالميه بدات
تشتري اراضي واماكن في الميتافيرس دي
وتعمل عليها مشاريع علشان المستخدم لما
يخش بالافاتار بتاعه يقدر ان هو يعيش
تجربه متكامله
فمثلا ممكن نشوف مشروع لمكتب زها حديد
اللي من اكبر مكاتب في العالم تصميم
المعماري
اللي بتدي تجربه للانسان كامله بيقدر
يلاقي بيوت يعيش فيها يلاقي اماكن يشتغل
فيها يلاقي انترتيه يقدر ان هو يقعد مع
اصحابه مثلا مع بعض في ميتافيرس
في الحقيقه التطورات دلوقتي حوالينا سريعه
جدا بالذات في مجال العماره اللي هي على
فكره مش مجرد مباني العماره بتعكس واقع
الانسان
ودور العماره ان هي تتاقلم مع الظروف
الانسان واحتياجاته في كل وقت
احنا ما نقدرش نتنبا بالمستقبل لكن نقدر
نصنعه
وربنا خلقنا كائنات متاقلمه نعرف ان احنا
نتعود على الاوضاع الجديده ونكمل حياتنا
والانسان كل شويه كان عارف يلا الحلول
لمشاكله
بمجرد ان هو يخرج بره دايره راحته لما حس
بالبرد اكتشف النار ولما حس بالضلمه اكتشف
اللمبه
لو انت لسه حاسس انك في زون فارجوك ما
تفضلش فيها كتير لان احنا بنتعلم وبننمو
بمجرد خروجنا بره دائره راحتنا
فاخرج واشترك في صناعه مستقبل احسن شكرا